all right Kelly
oh where'd you grow up where are you
from I'm from born and raised in St
Louis Missouri my whole life
um North County but I've fluctuated
throughout the city and you're a school
teacher there I am how long have you
been doing that so this is my ninth year
at my school
and what grade do you teach I teach 9th
through 12th
so we teach art you teach art
I'm sure you have lots of kids that
you're
in love with from your yes all your
classes yes being a school teacher is
really rewarding right it it is and they
become your own children I feel like I
tell people that I have 120 kids at a
time you have kids you're on that too I
do
and you're married with
uh how long you been married I've been
married 10 years
so you like living there it's a good
Community all that
um St Louis has its problems but as
we've been traveling through this city
we keep talking about how much we miss
St Louis and no matter how many problems
there are it's such a beautiful place
and in kind of a gym right
but something happened recently how many
years ago was it um it hasn't even been
a year so October 24th it will be a year
tell me what happened
so our school Community experienced a
school shooting
and he had 600 rounds of ammunition so
he came to take as many out as he could
he was a previous student that I knew
pretty well
um and it has created this crazy ripple
effect throughout our school community
and just the whole community of St Louis
it seems like there were casualties
there were two casualties not including
the shooter one of our rpe teacher
health and PE teacher and then one of
our 10th grade students
and how does that
impact the whole school I mean he's got
to just give you the worst thing ever
the
the shooting itself I feel like so many
of us heard so many gunshots because it
wasn't just like a couple gunshots it
was I counted just in one room
um the aftermath I counted 60 bullet
holes and that was without and I'd stop
counting after that
um which I think that was part of the
police shootout but the we thought
almost half the school was dead because
of the amount of shooting that was
taking place we felt like we were in
this like weird limbo of we felt like we
were being hunted that's what it felt
like like we were being hunted
um I was on the third floor with a where
a lot of the shooting took place
um and
I just could hear it so close and in the
echoing down the hall he pulled the fire
alarm to try and get us out so we're
hearing the fire alarm going off while
there are flashing lights we're we're
hearing all these auditory things and
the cops got there in four minutes
the one of our security officers that
rotates was able that has a gun was able
to get there and right before the cops
um and I have no doubt in my mind that
without
them doing such a quick reaction and
just rushing it and didn't meet at the
side just like ran in
I think so many more of us would have
died
um I know seven others were shot or
injured we were kids were jumping out of
two two three-story Windows
um
it's the healing process has just been
a crazy journey and I and I feel like it
was more than just our school Community
it was it was the whole Community just
felt it and like wrapped their arms
around us as much as they could
and this happened what month was it
October 24th October so you had the
whole school year after that yes
I'll go back until January so there
redoing the building cleaning up um we
did some virtual we did some field trips
so we were seeing the kids outside of
school if they could get there and that
was like something magical one of my
co-workers did to be like we have to do
something so we all kind of had our
little place in the healing process of
like who did what and how we were there
for the kids and I think we all kind of
picked these different roles if that
makes sense we went to job city
um I don't want to politically
politicize anything but we went to Jeff
City to China the red flag law would
have saved this whole situation from
happening I think a couple weeks before
they came and tried to take its gun but
because of all the laws they weren't
able to tell me about that
he um he was definitely mentally ill he
had tried to take his own life at
different points you remember him as a
student I remember him very well what
was he like
I I love all of our kids
um even our most challenging those are
the ones I actually tried my hardest
with
um I did not have him as a student but
it's a 400 person school we know all the
kids
um and I feel like I got to know him
pretty well he was very closed off he
had some he had friends but he I could
look in his eye and see that something
happened to him long before he ever got
to us I don't think we were the problem
if anything I think we were his only
safe space and when he didn't have that
anymore after he graduated I think there
was a lot of pain there this is all
speculation of just us kind of diving
deep but I think that's where a lot of
it took place I believe it was either
schizophrenia or some kind of psychosis
that was happening
um his mother tried to like get the gun
removed from the house they were able to
like give it to a family friend he got
it back they weren't able to actually
confiscate the weapon
um so he like had detailed notes and
planning and a map of the school he had
actually come to our school after he
graduated and he was really big into the
theater Tech program and I think that's
where he found his place and his voice
and he just wanted to help us so much
but it was still covered so we couldn't
do it and I think he just had this wound
of that there was no longer a place that
he was loved and safe if that makes
sense
and you've been you've been a teacher
for about a decade have you seen even in
that time the mental health of students
change not not from that event but just
in general oh yes
I have it seems like Society is getting
a little more
off track yes are our kids um it's an
inner city school with um 22 different
zip codes so some kids are coming from
the really bad part of town some kids
are come it's just all over there's so
much trauma there's so much gun violence
particularly so many kids are coming in
my cousin died last week from getting
shot he's 14. um and it's just something
that I've seen probably in the last five
or six years
um just just getting worse and worse
every single year
what do you views on gun laws
um I I'm definitely a firm believer on
we need more common sense gun laws do I
think we should confiscate every weapon
no but I feel like St Louis is kind of
like the Wild West
like everyone you don't I don't feel
like there are any gun laws if there are
they don't enforce them um so
you almost some of our kids will
literally say I have to have a gun in my
like I have to have a gun in my
neighborhood Miss Terry and that like
breaks my heart when a 15 year old
thinks that
um and these are good kids these aren't
like
kids running the streets these are kids
that are just scared for their life and
I think
I think that is just incredibly
it's shocking that that it's escalated
to this point
do you know the parents of the
the boy I do not
he told us false things he told us he
was in and out of foster care come to
fines that wasn't real like so there was
a lot going on there that I think we
just will never know
what what do you think there have been
so many school shootings in the last few
decades
because that didn't happen when I was a
kid yeah I you know a Columbine happened
when I was younger but it still wasn't a
fear I never ever went to school I know
it seems to happen a lot I am scared to
death to let my daughter go to school um
I let her but she started middle school
and like I think every parent should be
scared and I hate to say that but you
should be scared because if it can
happen in our school we have the most
magical school it's an art school it's a
visual art it's a performing arts school
it's such a healing loving beautiful
place and no matter how underfunded or
how crazy education is we always make it
work
um and if it can happen at our school it
can happen anywhere and I don't think
anyone should feel safe and I hate to
say that but I think it's true
DC impact on the on the kids after this
event yeah we went from having like
maybe one or two fights a year which in
the inner city that's like unheard of I
feel like at schools you know
most schools even just no matter where
you are to like almost every day we were
having a couple fights after and it was
all trauma it wasn't even like we know
the kids so well that it was so outside
of their character it was so outside of
who they were
um we were just seeing lots of kids
bringing up old trauma so so much and
teach like teachers as well all of our
old traumas from whatever whether it be
childhood or even adulthood but like all
of it was just brought to the surface
and I think everyone's even still kind
of touch and go in like when Tennessee
happens that was still pretty soon after
our shooting like teachers were missing
kids were missing like no one was able
to even come in because we were so
distraught so I think that's something
else is when the next one happens like
how are we supposed to function that
week at school
how has this changed the way you
interact with the kids with your
students
um I am always like loving mom nurturing
um
I think
I cared a lot less about
academics and getting stuff done and I
cared a lot more about like real worlds
um and like let's not push you into
college if that's not your purpose like
let's get you somewhere where you belong
um no matter where that is
I think just like being the art room
being this therapy safe space
um has even I've Dove further into
I don't think the kids have changed that
much as far as how I interact with them
it's more of like how I interact with
the rest of the worlds that has changed
how do you think
like parenting has changed that
so many young people are just like
mentally off
I think we're all stressed I think life
is difficult now yes like it's expensive
I'll I screw up as a parent all the time
and I'm like oh my goodness my kids
mental health is suffering because my
mental health is such a mess and it's
like this trickle-down where like
parents are working most parents are
working nowadays like instead of just
like a mom being home with the kid
that's rare I've noticed it seems like
so many people are
slaves to their work schedule yes the
parenting becomes like a yes like I am
not the best parent after I come home
after hearing all these kids
tell me these crazy stories that's going
on at their home like it's hard to come
home and be a parent and I'm sure a lot
of other careers are the same
what's your biggest concern now
if you're seeing this
my inward circle is like how are us that
we're in the building
gonna function because we appear like
we're still strong and fine but like I
was at Navy Pier last night I'm like
someone that hasn't gone and I'm like
freaking out like I don't trust the
world at all and I used to be
a more loving trusting bubbly person I'm
colder so I'm scared the kids are going
to have that then the Ripple outward
effect of like how is just this gonna
continue to to be a fear every time you
drop your kid off you don't know if
they're gonna come back so like I'm
constantly worried about my kids I'm
worried about the kids at schools other
schools like it's not safe it's not
how do the the shooting happened how did
it start
so it started he wasn't an actual
student anymore no he shot out a door
um crawled through he had like an some
type of a I'm not a gun person some type
of long gun assault rifle type but you
shoot out a door that makes a lot of
noise yes um but we have a pretty
stretched
school
um everyone
did their job that day like
we worked so it just proves how special
my school is because every single person
made sure that that information got to
the right person to call we call it it
Miles Davis so like that was our
Intruder drill was Miles Davis is in the
building and thank goodness one of our
people were watching the security
cameras unfortunately one of the
casualties happened before we were on
lockdown because like how how do you
even get on lockdown like it's a chain
of events with a school that large
um
but they were watching the cameras and
they ran in and they saved our life that
day
um I I don't know if I should name call
or not but we call her Mayor Johnson and
she will forever have a place in my
heart because I really feel like she
saved our life that day he made it up to
the third floor really quick I don't
know why he came straight to the third
floor I don't know if he was
specifically targeting or or if he had
weird memories there but he was just
he shot it a number of people before
they were able to lock down some of the
administrators some of them security
guards and his gun jammed
and they just like
I don't I don't really know what higher
power or what was looking out for them
that day but um he wasn't very skilled
with his weapon thank goodness because
even when he shot into the classroom he
was missing kids and he wasn't doing any
fatal shots
um for for some of the kids that were
wounded like two people died but how
many were shot
um I know seven were were wounded I
believe like six of them were shot I
think one of them was through jumping
out the window there was there was some
um
some trauma to the body then
um I still haven't pieced together every
bit of it
um
but where my building was my side
there's no way we could jump out the
window
um we would not have made that so we
were just trapped
um while every everyone was trying to
scramble if they could or just stay
silent
I mean that's what they train you to do
is stay silent but I don't think that's
necessarily effective either
because he knows all those trails and a
lot of people know
the ins and outs of those drills if
they're gonna
do something like that and emotionally
this is got to change everyone
what kind of stuff do you see the kids
going through
I I really think it's the bringing up of
the old trauma that I've really seen
like some of the kids have just come
with the most
horrific stories of childhood trauma
that they've shoved down that it's like
resurfacing and they don't
I think they understand like why and how
and why is this coming up like this is
old it should be more about the shooting
um I think some kids are scared we had a
it wasn't a fire drill the fire
malfunctions and no one some of us
wouldn't leave the room because we were
so triggered that what like this wasn't
a drill this wasn't planned what if it's
someone trying to shoot up the school we
wouldn't leave the building so there's
just so many
um auditory triggers I've noticed
um we heard we hear something in the
hall that is an echo and everyone's kind
of like startled and jumpy lots of
anxiety yes Lots what was this kid like
I mean did he have friends when he was
he did have friends in his notes that he
wrote I don't I didn't get to see all of
it but they kind of give us pieces of it
he said he never had a girlfriend he did
he said he never had friends he
definitely had a friend group he was not
bullied at our school I mean everyone
Jones on each other that's just like a
cultural thing
um it seems like we all kind of do but
it's it was never like he did not get
bullied at our school that was never
like an issue at our school so it was
very apparent that this was
childhood things that he was bringing
and with so many mental disorders and
who knows what else is going on it could
have could have been in just a psychotic
break where he oh yeah well and he had
been I know for a fact that he I think
it was over the summer before this
happened that he had been in and out of
like psychiatric hospitals and he
definitely this was like
definitely a suicide mission
um he didn't obviously want to live it
was very apparent if he's going up to
the third floor to do a shooting that
that kind of tells you he's not looking
to get away yeah and and there's some
video it doesn't show much but there's a
lot of auditory things and like he
busted in the room and he was taunting
some of us and
y'all are gonna die today and and and
things like that that you could hear on
the video and and through students word
of mouth as well and he was definitely
like taunting and I he played a lot of
video games I'm not like blaming that
but I do think that that was creating
like this fantasy where it was like
he wasn't realizing maybe it was as real
as it was he already knew he wanted to
die he didn't want to just go down with
suicide he wanted to be known
um that's kind of what I've compiled
from everything
thank God the gun jammed yeah
I mean 600 rounds and that was after he
was shooting a bunch
they brought us through the scene where
he was shot I don't know what I didn't
see him but there was like bullets
everywhere like we were
there was a way that we could have went
down the stairs the other way I don't
know why the cops brought us through the
crime scene that's the only thing I
haven't complaint about because they did
everything else right everything
um I think they were just also they
looked scared I've never walked out and
seen so many police officers and seen
fear on their face like I think they
were in shock as well
um even the ones that didn't see or
experience that part and were just kind
of helping evacuate and I think they
just saw the looks on our face and you
could just see some trauma there as well
Kelly what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in all of
this
I've learned
that I'm never safe
that was my safest place like I created
such a safe art room like this safe
sacred it's almost holy I'm not
religious but almost holy space for the
kids for me
um that's been my room for almost nine
years that's my only teaching experience
and to know that your Sacred Space can
be
just dismantled in a matter of seconds
and taken away from you in a matter of
seconds makes me feel like that could
happen to my house that could happen at
the mall that could happen anywhere I go
so I'm like constantly over alert over
aware anxious I catastrophize everything
because I'm like where are the exits
like what this and this and this could
happen and it kind of prevents me from
living
if that makes sense
that's sad
for everyone
all right Kelly thank you so much for
sharing your story let's hope this never
happens again thank you thank you very
much